what I'll be going with my name and
welcome to Falcons Fridays with
PewDiePie I hope you bros had a nice
week and after Walking Dead ending I've
been kind of like just melancholic just
be like nothing really matters in life
anymore I have a lot of stuff to open
and we're gonna open some fat like why
why why do you spend money to send me a
Gideon maybe it's like a magic stick let
me try it
simcha Bambi did it work did something
happen I don't think so hello Paley do
you want a steak
no don't you must prepare for the great
battle against evil patatas potatoes
then you will dance like this then you
will dance like this okay and also the
stick is from Sonya
that's a cute I'll never understand what
so first of all we have hey you talk and
then do this sometimes barrels are good
they can carry duties Wow the hell
wasn't I once Jeff it but I really got
it
yeah effects like yeah oh I know a lot
of you brothers are like oh you got a
play a Misha and stuff like I read my I
will never keep doing the same thing I
think I don't know maybe I will but I
just I just kind of feel like if there
are any sure custom stories that I
haven't played that are good and fun
then yes I will play them there are a
couple that I'm looking out for but if
there is just me playing the same type
of thing over know where it gets really
boring for me and I'm sorry I'm not I'm
not gonna do that even if you want me to
stay off and brass alright so this is
always nice to see when you open up ha
ha okay - just [ __ ] I'm a little like I
don't know what you could send me you
can literally send me any wing and if I
see something like this I'm like it does
not look nice and I do not want it [ __ ]
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] it's amazing but why
am i a unicorn
yeah it's me and fonta inside the county
oh you know what brownie or none brownie
I approve this little thing skip
these are awesome it's like a and
wristband like you got as me yeah yeah
such and I guess got PD on the back and
we got Jennifer got the bro we got stuff
ah there's also I don't know who that
it's but that's amazing Thank You Man
I love it from your super hardcore Bruce
Lee Anne and Joseph let's see what they
got here it's literally just the stone I
don't know why you bother to kits any
few stones it's gotta be expensive
oh well and then we got a skull with a
nice butt so you know you can't go wrong
with that a lot of stuff in this one ah
it's full ya know my my girlfriend will
love this thank you
not this oh okay
thank you I now have a bunch of cells in
my room that's really nice hey Olli I
wanted to thank you for all your videos
they bring me smile to my face in the
worst times
okay thanks for everything you do kids
bro freeze Kaley oh it's real nice broke
Hey and some pie aren't they the same
kinda all right yeah oh yeah oh yeah
thank you for what for making me smile
and laugh on a daily basis you're
hilarious and I love every single one of
you
isn't that like brothers Tim Brown hi
I was nothing with like hey I love this
fan art it's awesome can't open this
freakin packet I know okay can actually
change the good years who woulda thought
I just know what you do I just love who
you are and I have a complete and total
faith in you thank you for making the
world a little brighter rube alright
real face thank you seriously
that was a really nice letter oh it's a
flatter fuzz Fred to the mud I gotta
it's the door oh uh thank you rock
that's really nice
it's an ice weird smiley face I don't
know what you know what if there's ever
a zombie apocalypse I'll be using this
it's also I like it
[ __ ]
is this like a chiffon howdy partner
my name's Pierre de path and I'm here to
kill him
[ __ ] Zambian zombie apocolypse
set salvia that's awesome they even
painted the cat to make me that's
awesome oh it's magnificent look at it
hey you know what
that is awesome I think next time I I go
and apply for a job this with my resume
right here that'll be like hey what is
your qualification job right here this
is it
when do I begin oops I'll step and alone
awesome fan out there and bang it I love
it I can take it off ha ha ha it's a you
girls pink okay I don't know what it's
called you hang in the Christmas tree
okay
dasu Hey Oh his hands go up
oh yeah it's cool
all right price thank you for being
awesome stay awesome I know you will
really those things for all these
support bras and without you there's no
way I would be doing this videos
anything from a simple comment to
literally whatever you want to do it I
still really appreciate that people take
so much time I feel so undeserving you
have no idea it almost makes me cringe
when I see all this talented fan art and
all this thought that you bros put into
stop Bay I really feel like I don't
deserve this but hey I'm not complaining
and I love you bros for it so thank you
that's added with the brofist say
awesome press pheromone activate